[Musica]
Allora quando abbiamo pensato Quale
poteva essere il titolo di questo
intervento Abbiamo appunto pensato
l'equilibrio della sostenibilità quando
l'ho detto a Stefania ha detto Bel
titolo e dico Beh suona bene Poi quando
ho cominciato a fare la presentazione ho
pensato l'equilibrio della sostenibilità
in realtà è quasi una figura retorica
dell'impossibilità una linea Thun ho
scoperto che si chiama di fatto la
natura
questo lo dicono anche appunto
si occupa di ecologia la natura non ha
un equilibrio La natura è un flusso in
evoluzione continua in movimento non si
trova mai in una situazione statica
quindi pensando alla natura non si può
parlare di equilibrio Ma appunto di
Rossi poi pensando alla sostenibilità
antropica e tra l'altro non amo non ho
mai amato il concetto di sviluppo
sostenibile e ho sempre pensato Quale
poteva essere una una alternativa a
questa locuzione o questo concetto
perché non è solo una locuzione e l'idea
che da un po' di tempo insomma la più
forte è quella della evoluzione
sostenibile che mette un po' insieme la
natura e questo impatto dell'uomo Tra
l'altro l'ho anche proposto a Savage la
tuchel il creatore della crescita felice
ma mi ha assolutamente ignorato Però io
sono ancora convinta che possa essere
una soluzione quindi di fatto
l'equilibrio in generale in natura non è
una situazione normale qualcosa a cui si
tende e questa immagine per me appunto è
questa lo stato in cui io personalmente
anche Mi sento sempre e devo dire che mi
sento anche a mio agio in una situazione
di tensione verso l'equilibrio e in
tutto quello che facciamo anche in tutto
quello che riguarda l'energia sia
veramente in tensione verso una forma di
equilibrio qui Quali sono i disequilibri
gravi che stiamo vivendo in tema di
ambiente di natura di sostenibilità
questo probabilmente l'avrete già vista
è una miniatura in realtà
l'installazione e che sta a Berlino l'ha
realizzata questo artista Isacco
e vuole rappresentare appunto un
consesso di politici che dibattono sul
cambiamento climatico e vuole appunto
enfatizzare il fatto che mentre sono lì
che discutono
sul tema di quanto stanno già affondando
e se pensiamo oggi un dibattito su
questo argomento addirittura si sta un
po' spostando non si batte neanche più
di cambiamento climatico ma di Come
riportare il nucleare Ad esempio in
Italia o di come portare la transizione
energetica
trattenendola quella diciamo basata su
del rinnovabili e spingendo di nuovo il
fossile le fossili di nuovo il gas
quindi di fatto questo dibattito
impoverendo e diciamo la situazione può
preoccupante
l'equilibrio del clima nel frattempo che
i politici di bastano è arrivato alle
porte delle città questa immagine
probabilmente vi richiamerà la memoria
quello che è successo recentemente nel
nel Romagna in Romagna il territorio la
metà dei territori delle cooperative
agricole è finito sott'acqua parliamo di
6000 ettari che sono andati sott'acqua
che corrispondono per essere per avere
una dimensione più familiare a 9.000
canti da calcio quindi parliamo di una
di un Evento epocale che appunto è
arrivato alle porte della nostra città
poi su questo tema di Ravenna e del
della Romagna attorno verso la fine
disequilibri riguardano
l'intero globo e stanno aumentando in
maniera importantissima anche appunto le
migrazioni interne ai paesi non solo
quelle da un paese all'altro che sono
quelle che vengono più enfatizzate E
percepite ma anche quelle che avvengono
all'interno di uno stesso paese qui
Guardate ci sono anche paesi tipo gli
Stati Uniti che hanno un problema e
parliamo di quante sono 540 mila persone
in un anno questi sono dati del 2022
Quindi è un problema importante queste
sono solo migrazioni legate al clima non
sono tutte gli spostamenti interni ma
sono solo quelli legati alla riflessione
climatica e quindi è l'alluvione alla
società alle strane Quindi è un evento è
una crisi che diciamo impatta su milioni
di persone in tutto il mondo sempre in
maniera Più significativa Il problema è
che è in disequilibrio anche diciamo gli
impatti
ricadono sulle
popolazioni disponibile sulle persone in
maniera diseguale qui vediamo indicati
ad esempio Vediamo quanto le categorie
diciamo più basse Entrate a reddito più
basso sono quelle che subiscono le
maggiori perdite il cambiamento
climatico e sono quelle che hanno però
inciso in maniera abbastanza
irrisoria sul cambiamento climatico Qui
abbiamo un 12% e la responsabilità
appunto delle classi più povere e
abbiamo che sono anche le più
impossibilitate a far fronte al
cambiamento climatico mentre viceversa
se andiamo dalla parte opposta vediamo
che si la categoria diciamo il 10% la
popolazione del chiaramente più alto è
responsabile di una misura importante
48% delle missioni a un'altissima
capacità di far fronte a questi problemi
ma e subisce delle perdite molto più
basse quindi c'è assolutamente
disequilibrio anche negli impatti di
cambiamento climatico
Qui si tratta di capire come dobbiamo
spostarci verso un equilibrio un sistema
centralizzato di produzione dell'energia
basato su fonti fossilis con sistemi e
con reti
idonea per fronte appunto Alla
diffusione dell'energia da pochi punti
verso tanti consumatori dobbiamo andare
verso un sistema di protezione diffusa e
con una rete attrezzata per gestirla
questa ovviamente richiede investimenti
richiede anche di crederci a livello
politico e di fare spostare proprio il
sistema di equilibrio del sistema e
questo tipo di
evoluzione diciamo può contare molto
sulla partecipazione collettiva e
insieme questo è un po' una un elemento
che caratterizza anche la vita
L'esperienza di nostra della cooperativa
di cui faccio parte è proprio il fatto
che solo insieme si riescono a
raggiungere dei traguardi che
singolarmente sono impossibili da
raggiungere
E questa spostamento verso la
transizione se vogliamo anche che
insieme a transizione giusta non solo
rinnovabile ma anche giusta è possibile
metterlo nelle mani dei cittadini dei
cosiddetti cittadini energetici uno
studio del 2016 di quel pianeta qua già
aveva intuito il fatto che al 2050 un
europeo su due poteva diventare un
cittadino energetico quindi un
protagonista di questa transizione non
solo un consumatore ma un consumomer
produttore consumatore e questi
cittadini energetici sono divisi in
queste quattro categorie sono le
famiglie quindi domestico si realizzano
l'impianto sul proprio tetto
le imprese che fanno altrettanto le
pubbliche amministrazioni percentuali
diciamo più piccola e poi le cooperative
energetiche Quindi quelle fatte di
cittadini di famiglie di imprese che
decidono di partecipare a un modello di
questa natura
Questo è un movimento che a livello
europeo
dal 2050 raggiungerà quei traguardi Ma
già oggi è un movimento che raccoglie
riunisce centinaia di migliaia di
cittadini europei Questo è un incontro
che si è tenuto nel mese di maggio
quindi un mese fa Praticamente ad Atene
e questa fotografia rappresentarono
eravamo oltre 200 cooperative tra
cooperative energetiche e comunità
energetiche riunite per dibattere
confrontarci e condividere buone
pratiche sulla tematica e capire fino a
dove si può arrivare e vi assicuro che
la sensazione di questo incontro era
quella di euforia perché si percepiva la
capacità di far politica dal basso di
trasformare un sistema
coinvolgendo con dei cittadini e la
transizione energetica che spesso è
presentata come patimento sacrificio
sofferenza e in realtà anche Euforia
partecipazione entusiasmo e questo tema
importante trasmetterlo e condividerlo e
capire che facciamo parte di un momento
in movimento molto importante anche lui
nel nostro piccolo in Italia adesso
siamo a 13.000 soci e abbiamo realizzato
stiamo realizzando Insomma delle piccole
raggiungendo le piccole grandi traguardi
questo è una turbina eolica collettiva
quindi realizzata grazie alla
partecipazione dei soci che hanno deciso
di versare una quota di capitale e così
facendo accedono a una tariffa pezzo
fisso che non è il prezzo più basso che
si possa proporre e il prezzo giusto
Cioè il prezzo legato al costo di
produzione ed è quello che a cui uno
dovrebbe ambire un prezzo che non
risente delle fluttuazioni del mercato
perché è legato a quanto costa
realizzare quell'energia e questa è una
festa come vedete l'abbiamo inaugurata
nel 2021 ora abbiamo realizzato la
seconda turbine eolica sempre a Gubbio e
andremo a festeggiarla nel mese di
luglio
questo che dicevo prima il far politica
dal basso e far politica con il
portafoglio se vedete questo grafico
Quello è il prezzo dell'energia nel 2022
le fluttuazioni che abbiamo subito il
partito tutti e sofferto anche le
imprese hanno sofferto pesantemente e
quello sotto che sta fisso è il prezzo
dell'energia quindi questo voto col
portafoglio è un portafoglio che
Ringrazia in questo caso e ha portato a
risparmiare più di 500 euro una famiglia
che ha scelto di partecipare a questa
cosa senza la promessa di avere il
prezzo migliore non è quello il punto Il
punto è avrai un prezzo giusto legato a
quello che costa fare prendere tutte le
energie
qui l'altra strumento potentissimo per
partecipare alla transizione energetica
e quello delle comunità energetiche
rinnovabili probabilmente l'avrete
sentito perché è un po' diciamo un
tormentone facciamo
decine e decine di conferenze Su questo
tema e se abbiamo diversi progetti le
comunità energetiche sono una modello
che è stato introdotto da una direttiva
Europea pubblicata nel dicembre del 2018
e ha un prodotto questo questa
possibilità di aggregare intorno ad un
unico soggetto giuridico famiglia
imprese ma anche enti locali quindi
Nascono dei soggetti giuridici che hanno
l'obiettivo di
produrre e consumare localmente
l'energia e di condividerla tra i membri
della comunità energetica e grazie a
questa possibilità possono accedere
diciamo a delle forme di incentivo ma il
punto è che l'aspetto economico che
viene spesso enfatizzato quando ti vuole
proporre diciamo commercialmente è uno
che quasi un aspetto che può passare in
secondo piano perché se andiamo a
ragionare sugli obiettivi dei millennio
che vedete qui 17 obiettivi questo tipo
di strumento agisce su molti di questi
obiettivi agisce sulla possibilità di
accedere all'energia perché è uno
strumento che vuole privilegiare anche i
consumatori vulnerabili Quindi voglio
aiutare a combattere la povertà
energetica è una comunità Quindi si va a
costruire qualcosa che a livello sociale
genera delle nuove opportunità nel
territorio è una possibilità di creare
di produrre e di consumare in modo
responsabile che contenente aiuta
abbiamo anche dei progetti un progetto
si chiama comunità energetica
rinnovabile di pace perché è un progetto
che nasce dalla condivisione
dell'iniziativa tra la grande mossea di
Roma e il le strutture del Frate minori
Quindi addirittura interreligioso Questi
strumenti sono hanno potenziali che
possono assolutamente sorprenderci e che
devono ancora essere totalmente espressi
perché manca ancora un decreto attuativo
di questo percorso ma sono assolutamente
generativi
Qui abbiamo l'esempio in una in una
comunità energetica che abbiamo
affiancato in Sardegna il Sindaco quando
è nato questo soggetto giuridico e il
comune ha deciso di starne fuori per
lasciare che avesse la sua autonomia ha
detto Da oggi in poi questo è un
soggetto
politico che io andrò a consultare
quando vorrò proporre delle nuove
politiche locali quindi è qualcosa che
va bene Al di là della produzione del
consumo di energia e degenerativo perché
poi ovviamente per come intendiamo anche
il modello cooperativo è quello di
coinvolgere anche i ragazzi nel decidere
come utilizzare le risorse che vengono
generate dagli incentivi e quindi c'è un
coinvolgimento al punto di vista sociale
Questa è la storia più bella secondo me
in Italia non è un progetto che abbiamo
seguito noi questo ragazzino Gennaro è
un ragazzino di San Giovanni a Teduccio
nel Napoli est che è nata questa
iniziativa e lui si è appassionato
all'idea e ha cominciato a promuovere la
partecipazione alla comunità energetica
facendo il portafoglio andando a
raccontare che cos'era più opportunità a
coinvolge re le persone al punto che
Mattarella ha deciso di inserirlo della
onorificenza di alfiere quindi di fatto
questa iniziativa in un quartiere
fragile molto
complessi con molte complessità e molte
difficoltà
la storia di questo quartiere è stata
riscritta perché da questo momento loro
hanno capito quanto possono partecipare
ad aver ruolo attivo e quindi di fatto è
cambiata completamente la percezione la
condizione di questo quartiere
dicevo che sarei tornata sul tema del
dell'alluvione della Ravennate Questa è
la forza della Cooperazione che va al di
là della tematica solo energetica e un
tema che tu sta particolarmente a cuore
questo signore che vedete il presidente
della Cooperativa CAP terra che è stato
contattato dal prefetto e gli ha detto
per salvare Ravenna quindi per salvare
il centro urbano di Ravenna abbiamo
bisogno di rompere l'argine ed invadere
sotto i tuoi canti lui non ci ho pensato
un secondo e ha usato i suoi terreni
quello che era per lui l'attività
lavorativa che da lavorare a centinaia
di persone l'ha usato come un bene
comune
una possibilità questa richiesta e di
fatto per loro per i prossimi tre o
quattro anni Evidentemente non ci
saranno raccolti quindi ha fatto un
sacrificio il papa e tutti i soci della
Cooperativa erano d'accordo con
postazioni noi li conosciamo Anche
perché con loro stia facendo dei
progetti di comunità energetiche per cui
abbiamo deciso di
sopportarli e abbiamo avviato una
campagna l'abbiamo chiamata Un abbraccio
e bracciante perché queste sono le
cooperative agricole di braccianti per
raccogliere risorse da destinare a loro
per aiutarli poi non solo economicamente
ma anche poi con il supporto che daremo
successivamente per riuscire a
ripristinare quei territori Se volete mi
dice il QR Code non posso dargli se si
può riprendere Comunque è una una
espressione di quello che è il sesto
principio la cooperazione tra
cooperative e il suo del settimo
principio il fatto che le cooperative si
prendono cura dei territori e questa è
la forza di questa iniziativa condivisa
devo pensare a quali sono gli
ingredienti per
andare verso l'equilibrio non sono
tecnologia scienza o elementi di questa
natura L'importante è mettere al centro
elementi uguali in sogno gentilezza
entusiasmo
riuscire a tradurre
Questi elementi in
momenti trasformativi è sicuramente un
modo per produrre un cambiamento per
incidere E come dice Leonardo Mezzetti
una economista celebre economista dice
che l'unica cosa che ci rende felici è
essere generativi E tutto questo
processo che ci porta a partecipare alla
transizione energetica estremamente
generativo e sicuramente aiuta ad essere
felici Grazie
[Musica]